yeah joe biden what a kook i can't wait
till he meets greta thunberg can we get
those two together you know
have him creep out on her you know he
hugs her for too long he's like is it
global warming or is it hot in here
[Music]
she's like how dare you
i'm a big fan of asians i think they're
the best group i think they're number
one i don't think they get the credit
they deserve i'm an asian supremacist
all the way i think they're better than
the rest any asian people here
hey all right you should be working come
on
what are you doing having a good time
that's not the asian i know god damn it
i want you dealing blackjack or sitting
on a box peeling something come on
i mean this is a tough time in history
for black people black people are going
through it the two people have it tough
right now are black people and women
named karen they're having a tough go
um
but yeah yeah poor black women there
they're there they got hit hard by the
disease you know which i'm shocked by
because black people are so strong i'm
surprised i thought they'd be fine with
illness i mean look at magic johnson
he's still kicking right
he's doing great hell he beat kobe
people like try to figure me out through
my act it's all jokes i told an abortion
joke recently and a woman approached me
she was like hey that's very insensitive
i've had an abortion you shouldn't tell
jokes like that i was like whoa hey
sorry i just told a joke i think what
you did was much worse
i saw a bunch of people online are
saying racist [ __ ] to asian people i'm
like look if you're gonna type a bunch
of race and [ __ ] to asian people don't
do it from an iphone all right have some
respect for the kid who made it
because a dick and a gun are very
similar if somebody pulled out either
one right now we'd all be like whoa is
that meant for me jesus christ
don't point it at me damn
dick and a gun very similar both pointy
they shoot things they come in different
sizes you can get a pistol or a shotgun
i'm circumcised so i'm sawed off
the idea of your parents having sex is
so horrifying isn't it that's why i'm
surprised parents will use that as a
threat
wouldn't that be so effective like hey
timmy you better clean that room me and
your mom are gonna go at it
all right how'd you let math test billy
i got a d i'll show you some d all right
now you're allowed to be hateful in
america as long as you're not specific
you know if you go i hate jewish people
everybody goes oh my god what a bigot
prejudice but if you go i hate people
everybody goes
tell me about it
thank god dogs can't talk we'd all go to
jail right
just some chihuahua in a courtroom like
first he flipped me over
then he caressed all eight of my nipples
then he slapped me on the ass repeatedly
and said you're a good girl good girl oh
god
we harass dogs all day long and they're
appropriate harassing they can't talk so
they'll never report you that's why
they're man's best friend
also dogs forget stuff after like two
seconds you could stick your finger up a
dog's ass be like well that was weird
frisbee
boy i hate flying that's the worst part
about this gig i hate flying i like a
train give me an amtrak any day i love a
train trains have such low self-esteem
you know
no bag check no security it's almost
like they want a terrorist
i love it i hate flying flying is so
high maintenance flying's like a high
maintenance chick like you want to get
inside me you gotta hear an hour early
take your shoes off and do a body scan
you're like jesus christ
come on trains like a fat chick like get
a beer get in here
what a time we're living in i hope we
get the antibody test i don't know who
knows you know who's probably immune to
this [ __ ] is uh the two girls one cup
chicks i feel like uh
i feel like they're gonna be fine you
know
those gals can take a lickin
um
love the gays gay guys are the best i
don't get the whole homophobia thing any
homophobes here
i think homophobia can actually be kind
of dangerous you know friend of mine
he's kind of a tough guy he went
skydiving recently he's like yeah i'm
not strapping some guy in my back that's
super gay yeah now he's
dead you go
i like babies babies are fun you know
why babies are great because they're not
evil yet there's a million douche bags
out there but you never assume that babe
will become one isn't that nice that's
why no one ever goes up to a pregnant
woman rubs her belly and goes ooh this
one's gonna suck
no it's all up it's all potential it's
all positive oh it's kicking might be a
pro soccer player right so then we're
like oh it's kicking might hit his wife
my friend just got dumped so i took him
out tried to wing wingman him meet some
ladies for him didn't go too well you
know he got upset he's like screw this
let's go to a strip club i don't get
that logic you know to me that's like
going fishing not catching anything and
being like screw this let's go to the
aquarium
same thing
it's weird you're allowed to be hateful
in america as long as you're not
specific isn't that weird you know if
you're like i hate mexican people
everybody's like oh my god what a bigot
prejudice but if you're like i hate
people everybody's like
[ __ ] right
isn't that worse
people are angry now man i had one of
those uh white lives matter rallies
going to my house the other day i
freaked out then i realized ah just a
half marathon
sometimes i wish i was gay you know i
got fired from my last job for sexual
harassment i told a woman she had nice
cleavage they fired me which pissed me
off because my gay friends at work would
get away with murder they'd be like hey
shelly how are you honk honk oh
it's like what why is that okay like
well not attracted to women i was like
so what i'm not attracted to kids i
can't go to a playground hey timmy get
over here
i don't know what's going on the whole
country's nuts jimmy fallon got in
trouble for blackface like like what are
we doing that was 20 years ago why are
we mad at jimmy fallon the tv show put
it out nbc approved it there was a
writer's room why it was 20 years ago
you know what i was doing 20 years ago i
was banging a 16 year old
you can't judge stuff by
the later date i was i was also 16 20
years ago if you didn't
i'm not racist i look at racism the same
way i look at nickelback you know
yeah you know it's uh
it's fun to joke about but uh you never
want to see it live
i think white people are scared of
saying the word
black we're just trying to avoid that at
all costs we don't get in trouble you
know you could corner a white guy with a
microphone a video camera like what
color is ray charles he'd be like uh
he's blind
but what's his ethnicity piano player
what culture skin i got kids man come on
like i was on the subway recently i was
watching interracial couple make out i
was just staring at him
and the guy next to them caught me and
goes what the hell i see you staring at
them what are you racist i was like what
racist no i'm a creep
[Music]
see a [ __ ] complaining
never every other group complains never
[ __ ] never see it on the news sitting
at a desk legs dangling little fish
shaking
never
every other group complains i see women
on news we have a glass ceiling midgets
like you're worried about the ceiling
holy [ __ ]
i'm trying to [ __ ] with this counter
baby
i use the term breast implants because i
don't like the term fake breasts i like
the term it doesn't make sense to me
because the breasts are real it's just
the [ __ ] inside that's fake yeah the
actual breasts are still real it's kind
of like the bible the book is real it's
just the [ __ ] inside it's fake
i think we're all sick of this [ __ ]
though we're all i mean the corona is
kind of like the check engine light
you know when you first hear about it
you're like damn this is terrifying then
after a while like [ __ ] i gotta get to
work
this is too much
yeah
some people didn't buy it though my
uncle he looks at corona like it's the
tooth fairy he's like i know this is all
made up but i'll take the free money
how about a nice girl in that jewish app
what's that jewish app called the jewish
one uh what's the jewish act that not
the other one the other one uh paypal
yeah
i feel like poor people and gay people a
lot in common you know right both born
that way
yeah yeah women just want to be our
friends and uh
when you finally tell your parents
they're like yeah we knew
dates are tough now too because we have
no patience we want everything so quick
we want everything quick we have no
patience we want tinder fast food
delivery high speed internet everything
is so quick the only thing we want quick
is sex when's that going to catch up i
was with a girl the other night i
finished kind of early she's like hey
what's going on here i was like well
these are the times we're living in
come on i don't have the patience for
your vagina to be buffering let's go huh
you're an analog girl in the digital
world sister pick it up
my biggest fear used to be the bar
closing that was like my biggest fear
now my biggest fear is my phone dying
you know which is pretty good 100 years
ago we had real problems my baby's got
the black lung she might not make it
through the night i'm like i'm a two
percent i might actually have to feel
something
yeah who's got the energy to be racist
huh that's gotta suck to be racist
wouldn't that be weird just like you go
to the bank you're like ah this jew's
here i gotta leave
what a horrible life
man put on an outfit go to a meeting all
that stuff
i don't care about any group enough to
hate it do it whatever you want go nuts
i don't want to do anything i'm lazy i
don't want to burn a cross or a calorie
yeah
everybody's worked up about something uh
these there's muslims on airplanes well
i'd rather a muslim on a plane than a
baby
never had a muslim kick the back of my
seat and piss in the aisle
i'm just saying the airport had a baby
ban i wouldn't protest
i grew up in louisiana i grew up in
louisiana
yeah yeah i grew up with this guy hates
minorities every type of minority hates
them all which is weird to me because he
just had a baby
i find that strange because when you
think about it babies and minorities
have all the same negative stereotypes
if you hate minorities you should hate
babies too
you know
think about it babies are allowed in
movie theaters yeah right
they can't swim they all look alike
right they're lazy they don't work you
know
they can't drive terrible tippers
yeah they come to this country not
knowing the language
everything's weird now are strip clubs
open here
really so do the chicks have no clothes
on but are wearing a mask that seems
weird like hey here's a sloppy 20 i'll
put my nose in your butthole but don't
cough on me [ __ ] are you crazy
everything's backwards
i went skiing recently with my friend
we're sitting on the ski lift i was like
why do you see more black people skiing
why is that my friend has no idea but
he's gonna you know half-ass his way
through it because he don't want to see
him dumb so he's like ah you know
they don't grow up with it like well i'm
from louisiana i'm here well
skis very expensive all right right
right yeah yeah you know i've never seen
a black guy with anything expensive on
their feet
just say you don't know it's all right
you sound way worse that's why black
people are smarter white people we do
crazy stuff we swim with sharks we go
bungee jumping cliff diving ask a black
guy why do they do that i go i don't
know that's white people [ __ ]
that's a good answer
they don't sit around going uh you know
europe
i i ubered here that was i had a real
chatty driver huh don't you hate that
would it be nice if there was a small
talk option on the app you know
but there isn't so you got to really
find your own way to quiet the guy i
like to scare him you know he's like hey
how about this traffic what do you
think's causing this i'm like probably
the jews he's like
i don't know i'm just jealous you gals i
guess you know you know you got some
options you have the freedom to say no
like if a girl goes on a date with a guy
and this guy takes out his nazi
memorabilia she's like i get the hell
out of here if i go on date with a girl
and she takes out her nazi memorabilia
i'm like i gotta bang her and get the
hell out of here
could be a long winner
thanks a lot i'm kevin hart you guys are
great what a crowd thank you so much for
coming on i appreciate it praise allah
get home safe i'm gay thank you have a
good night creep it up l.a i love you